what was it like for you being on
Hollywood Boulevard in full makeup
costume and did any like random people
who were just on Hollywood Boulevard
come up to you and say that's incredible
makeup
uh it was so much fun I love that day so
much because you know it was like of
course like wearing the full costume in
the antennas and just to get to um to
react and to discover that crazy like
Walk of Fame as mentis was so much fun
uh actually people didn't come up to me
because uh it was just all extras so
people knew but still it was it was
awkward it was really fun well you know
what I mean though like even if you're
closed down filming there's always
people around like just you know walking
because it's just across the street yeah
I mean like even the extras like some
people were like who are you already I'm
like I don't know a mentis I guess do
you know the yeah I mean I'm not gonna
explain who I am
uh I definitely want to know what it was
like when James told you that uh Kevin
Bacon was going to be part of this uh
because it's such a great anyway it's
it's it's it's really funny and it's
great no but it was amazing and also he
was referenced several times in the in
the Marvel movies you remember in the
first a guardians of a galaxy with
footloose and then in uh at some point
in one of the Avengers movies I say like
Kevin Bacon so I even say the name and
that to finally get to work with him was
really fun it was like all written you
know years ago already so it was kind of
Genius you know what are you actually
most excited it's a little generic I
apologize but what are you most excited
for Marvel fans to see in the Holly in
the holiday special I mean I'm excited
about the big reveal at the end you know
so it it
it reinforces the connection between
mantis and Star-Lord and it's it's
really cute so I'm excited for people to
see that and also it's like a secret
that I had to keep for myself for years
so I'm finally I'm I'm relieved that
it's gonna be out there you know and
some fans speculated about it already so
it's cool what has been your favorite
part actually about being in the Marvel
Universe and playing mantis
I mean it's just um working with James
Gunn you know he wrote such interesting
and layered characters and and I get to
to play with it and and be weird and um
and and I think creating something
different you know and that's exciting I
I definitely have to ask you one other
thing though which is about something
else I am a huge Tom Cruise fan and I
think that he is amazing at what he does
and what he's willing to do for movies
so what has it been like actually
working with him and getting to see what
he's willing to do up close
it's I mean he's incredible to work with
you know he's so powerful uh so so
for powerful to see like it was like
almost like
um he's um he's so kind and so generous
and um you know he's like such an
inspiration you know he just pushes
himself
um like always challenges uh himself and
um yeah he's always a constant
inspiration what was it like for when
Chris McCrory told you that he wanted
you to be part of the next two Mission
Impossible movies because I can't
imagine what it's like to get that phone
call
oh my God I was I was so so so excited I
was so I was so happy and also so
stressed because I wanted to tell
everyone but I had to keep it a secret
for at least a few days but yeah it was
a dream come true for sure on that note
I gotta stop I'm just gonna say congrats
and I look forward to you know Guardians
3 mission everything uh have a fantastic
day thank you you too